we continue this half-hour with the case
against New England Patriots owner
Robert Kraft he pleaded not guilty to
two counts of soliciting a prostitute in
Jupiter Florida police say they have
video evidence of craft engaging in a
sex act he paid for at a massage parlor
but as Omar Villafranca reports the case
is raising deeper questions about sex
trafficking and the challenges
investigators face in containing it on
the same day the New England Patriots
won the AFC Championship in January
Florida officials allege that Robert
Kraft visited the orchids of Asia
massage parlor and paid for sex acts but
according to court documents released
this week craft through his attorney has
filed a written plea of not guilty to
two misdemeanor counts of solicitation
of prostitution
David Ehrenburg is a Palm Beach County
state prosecutor those who think this is
a victimless crime
that's an old way of thinking it's
missing the reality the reality of human
trafficking is stealing someone's
freedom for profit the 77 year old
billionaire is among hundreds of men
charged in a larger investigation into
possible human trafficking at massage
parlors located across South Florida
defense attorney Richard Kibby
represents at least a dozen men facing
similar charges to capture men and women
disrobing total nudity receiving
intimate massages to go after a
misdemeanor case I think a lot of judges
gonna have a problem with that even if
there's a crime committed on tape well
we're not sure any crime was committed
on tape or otherwise because from the
fact pattern we're hearing over and over
and over people went in for massages
some received something they didn't
expect they didn't pay for they didn't
bargain for they didn't want is that a
crime we don't think so but advocates
say human traffickers are known to use
coercion and force to keep women against
their will
often in plain sight some of the warning
signs are people who are living in
places that are obviously businesses
people who are not allowed to move about
freely that they are you know have to
ask someone else's permission to come
and go people who just don't sometimes
they don't look like their needs are
being tended to for CBS this more
Saturday Omar Villafranca West Palm
Beach Florida certainly not the last
that we've talked about now some big
questions confronting bully